i used to take the guys after after  christmas to pebble beach don cheadle  myself anthony anderson so cheeto had  some edibles i think he had like a  tootsie roll so on the fourth hole he  ate like half of a twisty roll but his  quad strength by the seventh hole it  wasn't good he wasn't getting in the it  wasn't getting it in the air you know in  the ninth tee box you could go to the at  pebble you can go to the snack bar  and then he took out the wheat i said  why don't we all eat it so you play nine  hole sober  and then at the ninth tee box you eat  the weed back nine you're you're [ __ ]  high right  and [ __ ] don cheadle wins with a  [ __ ] 11 on the 18th hole like it was  like 132 to  129. wow and every year  oh man they were  crazy high so  those guys said let's call it the  brownie cup